Ich hatte latent immer das Gefühl,
ich sei eine Extrawurst.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich habe mich
immer irgendwie schlecht gefühlt,
wenn ich irgendwie
schneller oder besser war.
Irgendwann begann ich,
mich dafür zu schämen.
Dann hast du extra langsam gemacht.
- Ja, genau.
Wunderkinder waren sie,
Bomi und Hani -
die zwei Schwestern aus Zürich,
die mühelos Schuljahre übersprungen
haben und v.a. als Geigerinnen
die Fachleute
schon früh zum Staunen brachten.
Wie geht es ihnen heute?
Und wie empfinden sie
dieses Prädikat im Rückblick?
Davon erzählt dieser Film.
Zürich, im Sommer 2006.
Die 12-jährige Bomi und
ihre 8-jährige Schwester Hani
auf dem Weg in den Übungsraum.
Wie jeden Tag verbringen sie
auch während der Sommerferien
einige Stunden mit Geigenspielen.
Bomi, die schon als Kleinkind das
Schülerlexikon auswendig konnte,
spielt meistens ohne Noten.
Am Anfang
spiele ich schon nach Noten,
aber ich versuche so schnell
wie möglich, auswendig zu lernen.
Das geht meist ziemlich schnell
und ist auch viel praktischer.
Dann kann ich mich
auf andere Sachen konzentrieren
und muss nicht immer
auf die Noten achten.
Die Eltern Herry und Kap-Keun Song
stammen ursprünglich aus Südkorea
und sind fürs Studium
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Seit ihre Töchter Musik machen,
verbringen auch sie
viele Stunden im Übungsraum.
Dort, wo so manche
grosse Karriere geendet hat.
Wir müssen ehrlich gestehen,
es geht nicht immer.
Es ist sehr menschlich,
wenn sie müde sind ...
Sie haben ja den ganzen Tag Schule,
dann unternehmen sie
vielleicht noch andere Sachen,
und dann müssen sie noch üben.
Das geht nicht immer.
Wir forcieren es nicht in dem Sinn,
aber wir führen
ein Gespräch mit ihnen
und machen sie darauf aufmerksam,
wie wichtig es ist, zu üben.
Dann kommen sie und üben.
(Mann) Hallo, Bomi, Hani.
Und dann folgt gewissermassen
der Lohn für die Mühe:
der Auftritt an einem Open Air.
Bomi hat
ein ungarisches Stück ausgewählt -
eine pragmatische Entscheidung.
Damit hatte ich
bereits einen Auftritt.
Deshalb habe ich es gut eingeübt.
Ist es etwas Schwieriges?
Nein, es klingt nur so.
Es ist ein Angeberstück.
Ein Angeberstück?
- Ja.
Magst du Auftritte?
* Lebhafte Musik *
* Applaus *
(U-Bahndurchsage)
Nächster Halt: Partnachplatz.
13 Jahre sind seither vergangen.
Die Schweiz haben die Song-Töchter
hinter sich gelassen,
mittlerweile
leben die beiden in München.
Das Geigenspiel bestimmt aber
noch immer weitgehend ihr Leben.
Bomi hat das Musikstudium
bereits abgeschlossen,
Hani braucht noch ein Jahr
bis zum Master.
Als Töchter asiatischer Eltern waren
sie vielen Vorurteilen ausgesetzt.
Ja, es wurde uns immer unterstellt,
dass unsere Eltern
uns immer voll gepusht hätten,
ohne dass diese Leute unsere Eltern
wirklich gekannt hätten.
Weil das eben
dem Klischee entspricht.
Und das hat mich am meisten gestört,
weil das einfach
überhaupt nicht so ist.
Die Leute haben einfach im Kopf,
dass alle asiatischen Eltern
ihre Kinder zum Üben zwingen
und dass alle Asiaten
keine Kindheit hatten.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das hat mich gestört.
In der Musik
kommt noch das Klischee hinzu,
dass Asiaten
nicht nur gedrillt werden,
sondern auch
absolut unmusikalisch spielen.
Also technisch perfekt,
aber absolut unmusikalisch.
Ich denke,
es hat durchaus Leute gegeben,
die uns mit diesem Vorurteil
zugehört haben.
Wir hätten
noch so schön spielen können,
es hätte immer geheissen:
"Ihr spielt nur technisch."
Hani, das hier ist kaputt.
- Darf ich es haben?
Hani und Bomi besuchen ihre Eltern
regelmässig in der Schweiz,
v.a. wegen musikalischer Projekte.
Beide spielen
in verschiedenen Orchestern.
Seit Jahren verdienen sich die zwei
Geigerinnen so ihren Lebensunterhalt,
finanzieren ihr Studium und
entlasten damit das Familienbudget.
Auf die Hilfe ihrer Eltern
sind die zwei jungen Frauen
schon lange nicht mehr angewiesen.
Ich denke, es braucht schon
die Unterstützung der Eltern.
Wir haben uns vorgenommen,
Bomi und Hani so zu fördern,
wie sie sind.
Wir wollten nicht aus einem Kreis
ein Dreieck machen.
Sondern wir wollten, dass der Kreis
grösser und grösser wird.
Natürlich muss es noch reifen,
aber ich denke,
sie sind auf dem besten Weg dahin.
Joelle Huser ist Psychologin,
spezialisiert auf die Abklärung und
Coaching von hochbegabten Menschen.
Für sie ist klar:
Hochbegabung gedeiht nur
unter gewissen Bedingungen.
Kinder und Erwachsene
sind häufig sehr sensibel
und besitzen
ein sehr feines Sensorium.
Wenn wohlwollende Menschen in
der Umgebung sind, die sie fördern,
dann können sie wirklich aufblühen,
dann können sie ihr Potenzial leben,
dann geht es ihnen gut.
Wenn sie aber merken,
dass Neid im Raum steht ...
... dass sie abgewertet werden,
dann kann es sein,
dass sie ihr Potenzial zurücknehmen
und nicht mehr zeigen können,
wozu sie fähig sind.
Das führt zu dem,
was in der Fachsprache
als Minderleistende bezeichnet wird.
* Sie spielt "Happy Birthday".
Die Eltern singen. *
Aufnahmen
von Bomis viertem Geburtstag.
Seit sie anderthalb ist, kann sie
lesen, Koreanisch und Deutsch.
"Liebe Bomi,
alles Gute zum Geburtstag."
"Deine Sybille."
Mit zwölf ist sie
längst im Gymnasium,
drei Jahre jünger
als ihre Mitschülerinnen.
Seven minutes
to work on this handout.
And then we form new groups.
Bomi bringt auch
erfahrene Lehrerinnen ins Staunen.
Das Ausserordentlichste
ist für mich,
dass sie sich
trotz des Altersunterschieds
so gut integriert
und so gut mitmacht,
dass man in vielen Situationen
gar nicht merkt,
dass sie so viel jünger ist.
Hani steht der grossen Schwester
in nichts nach,
auch sie ist ihren Schulkameraden
um Längen voraus.
Die Plappergeien ...
- Wo ist es?
Komm, ich lese es einfach mal.
Die Plappergeien stellen ...
... sich ...
Liest du oft?
- Ja.
... vor ...
... die ...
... neue ...
Hallo!
- ... Schülerzeitungsredaktion.
Ein Leben auf der Überholspur:
Durch die Schule rasten die Song-
Schwestern in beeindruckendem Tempo.
Trotzdem blieb genügend Zeit
für ihre grosse Leidenschaft.
Der Musik
seid ihr immer treu geblieben.
Aber stand das
irgendwann mal infrage?
Oh ja.
Ich hatte es nicht leicht
mit der Geige.
Das werden mir einige
nicht glauben, aber ...
Es war schwierig.
Ich war so oft verzweifelt und
so frustriert und streng mit mir.
Ich habe mich 1'000-mal gefragt:
"Wieso spiele ich
ausgerechnet Geige?"
"Ich könnte es
so viel einfacher haben."
Es hiess auch immer wieder:
"Du hast einen so guten Kopf,
wieso machst du ausgerechnet Musik?"
Ich glaube, ich habe
diese Herausforderung gebraucht,
ich habe mir beweisen müssen,
dass ich das auch kann.
Erst in letzter Zeit
kann ich mit gutem Gewissen sagen:
"Doch, das ist ein Teil von mir,
es gehört zu mir,
und wie es jetzt gekommen ist,
stimmt es."
Sind Sie stolz auf Ihre Töchter?
Ja, klar. Ich bin sehr stolz
auf meine Töchter.
Nicht weil sie etwas gut können
oder weil sie hochbegabt sind,
sondern weil sie so sind,
wie sie sind.
Und weil sie auf ihrem Lebensweg
gut unterwegs sind,
und auch wirklich
einen Reifeprozess durchmachen.
Ich bin sehr, sehr stolz
auf unsere Töchter.
Es ist schön, dass ihr sagt,
dass ihr stolz darauf seid,
wie wir sind, und nicht
wegen der Dinge, die wir tun.
(Mutter) Als Mensch.
- Genau.
Es ist schön zu erfahren,
dass wir zu Hause so ...
... geborgen sind.
Ich kenne viele, bei denen
die Eltern nur dann stolz sind,
wenn sie etwas erreicht haben.
Das ist mir extrem wichtig.
- Mir auch.
Und auch ...
Dieser Glaube an uns,
das ist etwas vom Wichtigsten,
was man von den Eltern
bekommen kann.
Egal, was wir tun,
ob Musik oder nicht.
Hochbegabte Menschen
werden noch mehr als andere
an der Leistung gemessen,
das baut einen grossen Druck auf.
Was auch hinderlich sein kann,
sind die hohen Ansprüche.
Viele Kinder entwickeln diese,
wenn sie immer
in einer asymmetrischen Beziehung
mit anderen Kindern sind.
Wenn sie mit der Zeit merken,
dass sie immer schneller sind,
schneller begreifen,
dann entwickeln sie einerseits
eine Art Hochnäsigkeit
gegenüber den anderen.
Natürlich nicht alle.
Oder sie entwickeln
einen Perfektionismus,
der dazu führt, dass sie, wenn sie
es nicht supergut beherrschen,
lieber nichts sagen
und sich zurücknehmen.
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Hani und Bomi traten seit jeher
immer wieder gemeinsam auf.
Ihr asiatisches Aussehen und
die Virtuosität schon im jungen Alter
machten sie fast schon zu Prototypen
von sog. Wunderkindern.
* Applaus *
Im Rückblick
eine zwiespältige Erfahrung.
Was machst du nächste Woche?
Gesellschaftlich war es für uns
eher ein negativer Stempel.
Oder wenn es positiv gemeint war,
dann wurden wir wie Tiere im Zoo
angeschaut - eine Sensation.
Das ist auch nicht angenehm.
Ja, ich glaube,
jeder Mensch will einfach
in erster Linie als der Mensch
angenommen werden, der er ist.
Und nicht als eine Sensation
oder als etwas ...
... Negatives.
Ich der Schule
war ich einfach immer die Streberin,
obwohl ich wirklich nicht
viel gemacht habe.
Ich habe mich immer dafür geschämt,
aber jetzt ...
Heutzutage merke ich immer wieder,
wie ich unbewusst
meinen Kollegen sagen will,
wie wenig ich für etwas mache,
bzw. ich stelle mich schlechter dar,
als ich es sein könnte.
Seit sie dreieinhalb ist,
spielt Hani Song Geige.
Was ist das jetzt?
Zu tief oder zu hoch?
Du getraust dich fast nicht,
es zu sagen.
Sie weiss ganz genau,
wie die Stücke aufgebaut sind,
welche Harmonien es sind, den
ganzen theoretischen Hintergrund.
Sie komponiert auch,
was nicht alle Kinder machen.
Die sind zwar auch begabt,
aber das tun sie nicht.
Sie hat
viele Mozartkonzerte gespielt
und alle Kadenzen selbst
geschrieben - und die sind gut.
Es ist dieses Ganzheitliche, das
mich bei ihr besonders beeindruckt.
Und sie hat eine Innigkeit, v.a.
wenn sie langsame Stücke spielt.
In diesem Alter
lieben Kinder Stücke,
die fetzen und Schwung haben.
Aber sie kann
mit einer aussergewöhnlichen Reife
z.B. eben
in langsamen Mozart-Konzertsätzen
unglaublich viel Seele reinbringen,
eben diese musikalische Reife.
* Tonleiter *
Inzwischen unterrichtet Hani selber.
Die Arbeit mit den Kindern
mache ihr grossen Spass, sagt sie.
Ein Detail: Würdest du sagen,
du hast den Bogen
immer richtig eingeteilt?
Manchmal zu viel, manchmal zu wenig.
Versuch's noch mal!
* Tonleiter *
Ich merke, dass dein Gis
oft ein bisschen zu tief ist.
Eins, zwei, drei, eins ...
Das kann ich nicht auf Drei.
- Machen wir noch mal Vierer.
Die Freude an der Musik
weitervermitteln,
ist beiden Schwestern
eine Herzensangelegenheit.
Hier am Gymnasium Moosach in München
machen sie das heute
im Auftrag von Rhapsody in School,
einer Initiative,
die sich genau dem verschrieben hat:
Schülerinnen und Schüler
für Musik zu begeistern.
Hani und Bomi als
Botschafterinnen des Geigenspiels.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Vielen Dank von unserer Seite.
Ich bin Hani,
das ist meine Schwester Bomi.
Ich bin 21 Jahre alt,
sie ist älter, sie ist 25.
Auch für den Rücken. Es ist eine
nicht zu unterschätzende Belastung.
Im Orchester sitzt man halt ...
Man sitzt halt 6 Std. lang so da
mit der Geige.
Versucht mal,
6 Std. in dieser Haltung zu sitzen -
da muss man aufpassen, dass man sich
nicht wehtut in 30-40 Jahren.
Und der wichtigste Teil ist Üben.
Üben, üben, üben.
Wir haben ... Im Musikstudium,
was übt man da - 3, 4 oder 5 Std.?
Ja.
Wenn's mal brennt, dann auch mehr.
Dann sperrt man sich auch mal ein
und übt halt 8 Std.
Wir haben euch eine ...
... Mischung mitgebracht
von allem Möglichen,
was man mit der Geige tun kann.
Ich hoffe, es gefällt euch.
Die Geige, die mittlerweile Leiden-
schaft und Beruf gleichzeitig ist.
So wie andere jeden Tag
ins Büro gehen,
müssen wir jeden Tag
das Instrument in die Hand nehmen.
Wir sind aber sehr froh,
dass wir doch mit sehr viel
Leidenschaft dabei sein können.
Natürlich,
es ist ein schönes Gefühl,
wenn das, was man macht,
gut ankommt,
wenn man auf der Bühne steht
und die Zuschauer sich freuen.
Das ist immer schön,
aber man muss jetzt nicht ...
Ich mache es nicht nur,
damit ich auf einer grossen Bühne
vor 1'000 Leuten stehen kann,
sondern es ist auch schön,
wenn nur eine Person zuhört.
Das gibt mir manchmal sogar mehr.
Grosse Auftritte
hat es schon einige gegeben.
Z.B. 2012, als Bomi in der Kirche
von Wattwil als Solistin auftritt.
Auch für die stets
so abgeklärt wirkende 16-Jährige
ein emotionaler Moment.
Hattest du schon viele
Standing Ovations?
Nein. Das war wirklich
ein tolles Gefühl.
Grosse Emotionen
am Anfang einer grossen Karriere.
Aber die Realität
bedeutet harte Arbeit,
auch für eine Überfliegerin wie Bomi.
Bis zur ersten festen Anstellung
sollen noch ein paar Jahre vergehen.
In München ist es dann so weit.
Warum hast du dieses Foto gemacht?
- Von dem ...
Damit ich es morgen posten kann.
Mein Arbeitsplatz.
Jetzt hast du es auch verstanden?
Und wieder ein super Gefühl für Bomi.
Hier an der Oper wird sie für ein
Jahr festes Mitglied des Orchesters.
Allerdings im Orchestergraben
und nicht auf der Bühne.
Das ist völlig berechtigt so.
Andererseits ...
Wir unten im Graben schauen,
dass alles läuft, alles sitzt.
Und ich bin auch
gerne mal im Hintergrund.
Ich begleite auch sehr gerne.
Und es ist toll, dass es am Schluss
etwas grosses Ganzes wird,
das das Publikum zu sehen bekommt.
Mit welchen Gefühlen
gehst du auf den morgigen Tag zu?
Ich freue mich wahnsinnig.
Ich bin gespannt, was mich erwartet.
Ich kann es
noch gar nicht einschätzen.
Aber ich bin sehr zuversichtlich.
Ich habe schon
Kollegen kennengelernt.
Ich glaube,
die Atmosphäre ist sehr schön.
Ja, ich freue mich
auf die neuen Herausforderungen.
Bist du auch nervös?
- Ein bisschen schon.